Paula Reid has covered the Russia
investigation since and began nearly two
years ago she's here to break down
exactly what Cohen's public testimony
may mean for the president let's start
first with this extraordinary revelation
that Cohen is going to tell Congress
that President Trump knew that Roger
stone was in touch with Julian Assange
and that WikiLeaks dump was coming
before the Democratic National
Convention why is that significant what
did the president tell the special
counsel Robert Miller it's our
understanding that the president has
consistently told everyone including
robert muller that he was not aware of
this so if the president's written
answers to the special counsel because
we know this is something special
counsel is focused on if those answers
do not match what other witnesses and
documents say the president could have a
problem that just because Michael Cohen
says this is what happened that is not
enough to establish that the president
lied but it does raise the question but
whether those answers match put it in
context what was happening at the time
because just days later the President
himself while campaigning for office
says directly hey Russians if you're
listening can you hack and get more
Hillary Clinton's emails he was
essentially egging on the Russians to do
more absolutely and people want to know
if it was more than just egging on and
suggesting was there any coordination
and was there anything that passed
between the campaign and Russia of value
were they working together was there a
conspiracy and this testimony today I
mean this raises more questions about
whether or not how much the president
knew okay also we're learning from Cohen
today here is a copy of the check that
the president was writing checks to
Michael Cohen while he was president of
the United States hush money payments
for stormy Daniels does that mean the
president did something illegal while in
office
Oh Cohen alleges that he received eleven
checks from the president while he was
in office and he said look this was part
of a plan to cover up campaign finance
violations and he alleges in his
testimony that this whole scheme was
directed by President Trump just two of
the incredible revelations we will learn
today under some tough questioning from
members of Congress
all right Paula thank you and